I knew that if I was going to college
and it wasn't to be a doctor I probably
didn't need to go and I didn't want to
walk away with all the debt and what we
were building was really exciting and I
said if this is what it takes to really
give it all you know to company I'd
rather do that honestly and I just felt
it was a better use of my time
my name is Joao pessoa and the founder
and CEO pilot and I'm 23 years old we
are a better fiber optic internet
provider for businesses across New York
Philly DC and Boston I spent four years
as the head of IT at we work and so I
was building out fibre to all their
buildings around the world and I found
this white space between the small
business internet providers and the
enterprise providers typically used by
banks and hospitals and I felt no one
was really addressing the needs of an
innovative company I think the aha
moment was realizing how big the market
opportunity was as we you know expanded
our business from new york to SF to
London to Tel Aviv I thought this was a
problem around the world and I wanted to
solve it
I think first and foremost we built the
entire business from the ground up
thinking how do we reinvent this
experience and we knew to do that we'd
have to kind of be vertically integrated
all the way up so everything we do is
all pilot employees focused on that
subscriber experience from construction
to network design to installation to the
end service experience when you call our
support center
[Music]
well over the course of a summer in 2010
I took out an office at the first we
work location and a couple of members
were having issues with their Wi-Fi and
printing and all that stuff I just
started helping out more and more and at
the time you know their IT person had
taken a trip to Brazil and ended up
staying there and Adam and Miguel said
hey Josephine do you want to help us
that's what it was at first it's just
our IT guy and then one building became
two and two became 10 and the rest is
history
because I had gone back to school after
the summer and I was juggling both
things simultaneously and we really
started to ramp up our kind of building
pipeline and I knew it wouldn't be
feasible to really keep doing though
that's why I think I ended up making the
decision in January of 2011 still in my
life I look you know five years forward
and I think to myself oh what do I want
to be when I grow up and when I made the
decision I knew that nothing is
irreversible and if I want to go back to
school I can find a way to make that
happen I just thought I have the chance
to be a part of a really exciting
opportunity and that's what I want to do
[Music]